okay why don't we go ahead and get
started want to welcome everyone to our
Thursday conference and actually today
is one of the days we're also
designating as an IDL talk which as many
of you know is our informatics discovery
lab our new initiative that's looking at
trying to build bridges collaboration to
industry and others outside the
university I spread the word of
informatics and part of that effort is
also tied into a larger ohsu effort
which is to try to get more interaction
between these two great organizations
that exist in in the Portland area which
are ohsu and Intel about 10 miles apart
but until recently not a just occasional
bits bits and pieces going on so to that
end we have started engaging the those
working in healthcare at Intel and so
we're going to start to involve them and
some of our IDL efforts and so our first
our first effort in that regard is
today's talk and we have Nancy vukovic
who some of you know because she has
worked over the years with Joan and
others in the department so she's no
stranger to de maiz but anyways she's
currently medical anthropologists and
director of user experience research in
Intel's health strategy and solutions
group and her research involves studies
of clinician mobility and hospitals
delivery of home-based primary care
and experiences of patients and family
caregivers during care transitions and
she currently leads a team of
ethnographers and user design user
interface designers in the US england
and china before joining in town nancy
was a p.i at the kaiser Center for
Health Research where she developed and
led health research health services
research studies and clinical trials of
behavior change interventions and
alternative therapies for pain
management nancy has a PhD in medical
anthropology from the University of
Arizona and also from Arizona a ma in
linguistic anthropology so I will turn
it over to her
sorry if you missed that first bit but
we've been involved in health care for a
number of years then until a lot of
people like wow entails doing health
care but actually we've been engaged in
healthcare research and design of
interventions for over eight years most
of that early work was focused on Aging
in Place technologies things like
sensors to detect Falls and changes in
gate as well as devices that might help
elderly people to stay in their home a
little bit longer we're still having a
threat of that but more recently we've
been working on strategies that are
really clinical in focus so rather than
personal healthcare kinds of things or
even Aging in Place we've been focused
on ways that we can help clinicians to
be more effective in to really enjoy
their jobs more you might say not
unencumbered by technology as it exists
today there we go so we have sort of
large group which is called health and
life sciences which deals with a lot of
different kinds of aspects of health
care including working with partners
like GE and others to develop technology
that that enables things like tiny
ultrasound machines and other kinds of
stuff but our particular group is called
health strategy and solutions and we're
really focused on trying to find
solutions in the clinical space things
that will help clinicians to do a better
job as i mentioned we're also involved
in research that looks at big data and
genomics and i'll talk about some of the
initiatives that we have in just a
moment but our basic approach to health
care in general in our group is to do
research some of which I'll describe to
you others that are a little more
clinical and focused because we partner
with a variety of different institutions
to understand clinical space we incubate
new ideas we try to come up with
solutions and then we will test them out
we might make either concept prototypes
that are really more like storyboards
and test them out with people and we
also work with other partners within
intel to create actual functioning
prototypes that we could bring before
clinicians and we're working with ohsu
on some of those things
right now in terms of using the new sim
lab when it gets developed to bring
those kinds of interventions to people
and try them out we also are involved
quite a bit in thought leadership so it
involves things like this coming to talk
to different groups talking at
conferences publishing papers in
peer-reviewed journals we try to as much
as possible make the work that we do in
the research that we do transparent to a
larger audience some of that of course
is proprietary but as much as possible
we can so for example research that I'm
going to touch on briefly today that we
did with the Veterans Administration we
just submitted to Health Affairs
yesterday finally so we really try to
get out the information as much as
possible and then we're also involved in
you know the bread and butter the
earning money for Intel which is the
go-to-market piece which is helping
Salesforce become trusted advisors when
they go out and talk to healthcare
clients so the work that we do our
understanding and deep knowledge of the
healthcare environment and clinical
space helps people make suggestions
about the kinds of technologies that
might be useful to people in both
Enterprise settings like ohsu and other
large hospital systems as well as
smaller organizations as well so I'm
going to go over a couple of the
initiatives that we have going we we try
to focus our energies where a rather
small team we're based in primarily in
Oregon a few people in California we've
got some folks in London and in Beijing
but it's still a pretty small group of
under 50 people trying to get a lot of
work done so we're trying to focus our
efforts as much as possible and one of
our big initiatives is healthcare
mobility understanding i'll talk about
this more when i get into the research
piece but understanding that our society
as a whole our world as a whole is more
mobile as in terms of how we access
information and where we do our work and
how can we bring the healthcare
enterprise into that space to enable
people to work in remote areas providing
care or even to be able to talk to each
other across campus and those are some
of the initiatives that we're working on
there we're also working on a
age-friendly cities initiative primarily
in China for those of you who might know
China unlike many other countries
in the in the world is facing an age
crisis in which a large portion of the
population is going to be aging there's
a smaller cohort of younger people able
to support those individuals and so many
governments are looking toward
technology as a way to provide supports
and care for people as they age without
having to institutionalize them or to
have them be kind of love stranded on
their own and we've been doing consider
bottom research and working with both
government telcos and other kinds of
organizations in China to see what we
can do in terms of supporting that
effort there and finally another big
area is big data and analytics so we've
been working with folks like ohsu and
other organizations try to understand
what needs are particularly in terms of
computing power and speed as we rely
more and more on genomics testing to
understand what would be effective
therapies for cancer and other diseases
how can we get to those answers quicker
for people so that patients don't have
to wait a long time so clinicians aren't
left in limbo and we could really try to
accelerate that whole process and that's
a huge I mean that's where our large
computing efforts come in because of the
amount of speed and computing power
that's needed to accomplish those things
so this before I go into the user
experience are there any questions that
i could take from people about intel and
its involvement in healthcare ok we'll
see if any come up by the end but let's
go on now to user experience and this is
where my team comes into play so I am a
medical anthropologist which means I was
sort of classically trained and how to
do fieldwork and ethnography and
interviews and all that kind of stuff we
also have working with those people who
come from different perspectives we have
anthropologist but we also have clinical
psychologist we have people who with
more of an IT orientation people who
come from design ethnography kinds of
backgrounds as well as people who are
visual people and it's really helpful
for us to have that kind of
multidisciplinary approach we all try to
use similar methods but having different
perspectives gives us a different eye on
a problem and you know whether it's a
variety of clinician
giving different perspective on a
patient and coming up with a really
solid care plan same is true and we're
talking about this kind of research when
you have different people looking at the
problem they come up with different
solutions we try to apply a pretty
rigorous approach to the research we do
so we don't typically just kind of jump
into something but we really try to
understand a circumstance before we go
into the field and that means we may
look at academic papers that were done
we do you know the ever-popular Google
search to find out what other people
have been doing we really try to as much
as possible understand the space so that
when we create a research plan we're
focused because unlike you know my my
time doing field work as a graduate
students when I had you know a year to
be out in the field our time is
typically much more constrained so we
really need to to hone in on a question
and try to understand what it is that
we're going to do and prepare ourselves
for that jump into field work so that's
the first part then we plan we you know
plan our methods we plan who we're going
to be talking to we plan a lot of
logistic you know sort of the boring
logistics of how we're going to get
there and what are we going to do kind
of stuff but the planning piece of it is
very important so that once again when
we get to a location we can be most
efficient and most or least disruptive
to the people that we're working with
because of course we have learned over
the years that when you're working in a
clinical environment clinicians have
about that much time that they can give
you so you really need to maximize that
time and patient care comes first so we
need to you know position ourselves in a
way that we can learn what we can but
not get in the way of what's happening
for patients so then we get it done
somehow miraculously we spend our time
out in the field collecting research we
do employ other methods besides just
observation and interviews I'll go into
that a little bit but you know we
implement our research plan whatever
that might be and collect the data that
we have part of that also then becomes
the harvesting of it so we in a
traditional sense we need to to manage
the data that we get whether it's visual
or transcripts notes from our fieldwork
we need to encapsulate those and make
sure that we have a have them in hand as
our data but then we also work with not
just the the people who are out in the
field but other folks that we can bring
and like for engineers architects other
people who have different perspectives
beyond our research team to huddle with
us and to look at the information that
we have and to see what we can come up
with in terms of what what do we think
is important that's going on here and
what kinds of things can we do to
address it so the harvest piece becomes
very important and it's our first
opportunity to kind of disseminate what
we know beyond our small group of
researchers and then the translation
piece comes in and at a place like Intel
that's very important because we need to
speak to a variety of different folks we
need to speak to engineers who are
thinking in terms of requirements we
need to speak to business folks who are
thinking about well what kind of
business model are we going to build
around this we need to talk to other
groups who have maybe no interest in
health care at this point but we need to
convince them this is an important issue
that needs to get on their roadmap or
that somehow we we like to partner with
them to create some solution so the
translation piece becomes exceptionally
interesting and will I'll give you some
examples of that just a minute so we
like to think in our group and we like
to convince others that ethnography
inspires innovation and by that I mean
when we go and immerse ourselves and
bring back the stories of real people
encountering real situations and
difficulties it helps people to become
more creative in terms of the solutions
that they provide it's sort of easy to
get some people who don't have exposure
to lock themselves in a room and come up
with some ideas but whether or not they
actually work in an environment is in
large part dependent on how well they
understand what the actual needs and the
actual environments and contexts are
that people are trying to work in so
once again we go and spend a lot of time
like this observing what people are
doing trying to capture images so we can
bring them back to the team that's not
there are they spending a lot of time
and saying what what does it mean that
all these people were clustering around
that one computer what does it mean that
that person is writing something on a
piece of paper as opposed to putting it
into a tablet or a laptop or some other
kind of device how is all that impacting
the kind of work that they do and the
kind of work like life that they have we
conducted a study and it's now close to
a year old and then we continue to add
to it but we had a large
research project that we undertook to
try to understand how mobile are
healthcare workers so we worked with
some consultants to expand our team
because we had a at the time an even
smaller team and an even shorter
deadline to try to get some information
together so we did research in the UK in
germany in two cities in china and in
the united states and spent a lot of
those times were concurrent weeks but we
spent a lot of time out in the field
observing people in different hospital
settings following doctors following
nurses trying to see what they were
using and how they were getting about
their work we began the study thinking
well let's let's shadow people who are
using tablets or using phones and as
part of their work and we did some of
that but quickly sort of change the
research project to look much broader
than that at not just devices that
people were using but other kinds of
factors within the ecosystem of the
hospital that we're affecting even a
person's ability to be mobile and what
other kinds of things were they using to
become mobile so one of the values of
the kind of work that we do as
ethnographers is that we have that
flexibility it's not just like a random
oh let's change things it's considered
and it's an iterative kind of process
but it unlike say for example a
questionnaire which needs to go out in a
certain way in order for it to be valid
and for you to collect the sample you
need we have that bit of flex within
ethnography and say there's something
else going on here how can we expand our
horizons how can we ask that question
differently or ask a different set of
questions in order to fully understand
what's happening within this environment
and so we did a bit of that with the
whole team and and because this was done
people who were in different places at
the same time we would often rely on you
know blogging to each other sharing
photographs doing that kind of stuff to
really be able to debrief because we had
somebody who is on us time and somebody
who was on china time and it you know
conference calls were not particularly
practical that at that point but we were
able to sort of feed each other
information and and have that change
disseminate pretty rapidly across all
the field work that was being done so
just wanted to have a look here and
at this particular photograph and when
we were starting to see things like that
we were seeing again we were looking for
mobility but then here is this is a busy
ER in a hospital in Chicago and all the
patients are lined up here and there
there in those rooms but all the staff
is here because what they have to work
with our desktop computers and cows or
Wow is depending on what you call here
but again that took them away what we
were seeing more and more is that
because people had to go here to
retrieve information and to document
information they weren't here at the
bedside and so how could we make that
how can we enable that having people
able to do things at the bedside and
still get in their documentation what we
were seeing was that people were doing
that but the means that they were using
to collect data here was a piece of
paper and a pencil which meant that when
they they'd have to go back and reenter
that day oh so there was double work
happening there or for those other
people would kind of retain it in memory
and then go back and enter the data
which you know as well know what your
memories like but it's a dangerous thing
if I were to do that so again how can we
really facilitate that whole process so
just a little bit more on methodology
when we talk about observation it's it's
really focusing on what's happening in
an environment and it's not usually just
like 15 minutes in an environment but it
may be an entire day or a series of days
that we spend to really try to
understand what all the interactions are
we're looking at what individual actors
might do like in the case over here this
was a the work we did with the v8 oops
work we did with the VA and we were
shadowing doctors and nurses who
actually went out provided primary care
in the homes of veterans and we were
trying to understand what what that was
like what that experience was like for
the clinician and what we learned among
other things was that that was their
work space station when they were in
someone's house it was that or a
footstool or their lap or some other
place where they had to do it and and so
the question for us became you know how
do we what kind of devices can people
use that I label them to work in those
kinds of environments when you don't
really know what the situation will be
like or even if you're going to have a
place to connect because
some veterans homes the the wiring in
the house wouldn't even support the kind
of electrical needs that the provider
might have we also look at interactions
between people and technology this was a
study we did up in Seattle where we were
testing the use of Windows 8 tablets
with clinicians in a Pediatrics practice
and we were seeing how how the doctors
were actually incorporating them into
their practice so how are they holding
them how are they carrying them into the
room were they showing them to the
patients and then how are they using
keyboard devices to continue their
documentation once they were out in this
case this guy we had a Bluetooth
connection so he was just like clapping
is tablet next to the keyboard and able
to use it but those interactions between
people and technology are another thing
we looked at so we've got people acting
we've got people on technology and then
we've got people in groups interacting
and how does that happen that's another
focus of our observation what is it
about the way that they communicate the
kinds of things that they use in the
form of retrieval or recording of
information that could tell us again
something about what needs are here we
have people trying to share information
you know again these residents are
carrying sheaves paper because they
don't have electronic access to the
patient records they're carrying them
along with us with them another
interesting piece about this which is I
think not a typical in hospital settings
is that there's limited amounts of
compute devices available for people to
use and so when you have two or three
teams rounding in a teaching hospital
and you have nurses who are distributing
meds at the same time it becomes a an
interesting cultural situation of who
has priority who access to those those
compute devices and how do they
negotiate who gets to use them so those
all kinds of factors that we think about
when we're doing our observation there
are times when we use other kinds of
tools as well we certainly use surveys
on occasion and we use things like you
know other kinds of stimuli photos and
other kinds of things to to get at
people's ideas of things we for this
mobility project we also conducted
workshops with the doctors
and we asked them to do things like plot
their day what their day was like and to
overlay other kinds of things upon that
that simple timeline of what their day
was like what kind of devices they used
what kind of people they interact with
with and what kind of emotions they were
feeling so we wanted to get at you know
what kinds of situations were stressful
because of the presence or absence of
certain kinds of technologies and it's
sometimes difficult to ask people those
questions off outright and sometimes you
can observe it because you see somebody
getting mad and you know like slamming
their laptop on the floor but you don't
always have those opportunities so we
need to come up with ways to get at what
we hope would be observational but is
not always and things like these
workshops are usually a really good way
of doing it because it gives people you
know gets people creative it gives me
something to play with and so that
untapped other parts of their mind
sometimes working in a group is really
useful for that because it kind of
lightens things up for people and what I
like about these in particular is that
people take them where they want to go
there are a lot of methods that you can
use like this but we have questions that
we come into the field with but we may
not know the right questions to ask yet
and if you give people the lead and the
research they'll often times come up
with stuff you didn't even think about
and that's really useful for us as we
modify our methods so I mentioned that
output is really important and in
particularly I find in a place like
Intel creating tools that you can use in
your dissemination process is really
helpful and we are very grateful for
people we have were much more visually
oriented than i am and able to produce
these kinds of things because this is
the kinds of things that speak to the
people outside of our group within and
especially outside of our group as we
try to tell the stories so we try to do
things like create personas and this I
think is a nicely done one in the sense
that it gives you sort of the basic
information about the person and as well
as you know maybe a quotation from them
the kind of tools that they use and some
more information about their work the
personas for those of you who might not
be familiar with this are usually not
eight
person but it's a it's a kind of
composite of the people that you've been
working with and it you create personas
that are archetypes of certain kinds of
parts or segments of your audience but
they are really helpful in terms of
getting people to think about who it is
that they're designing something for
they can kind of go back to these almost
as flashcards and say oh yeah he
wouldn't like that or she would like
that kind of thing as they think about
these is almost real people we haven't
done it but I've heard in other places
people actually construct life-size
personas I was at a conference recently
and they were talking about this and
they just like have them inhabit
different parts of their workspace so
that people always feel oh yeah I'm
doing my work for this person not for
some abstract thing we also try to
create opportunity maps so our I
mentioned a harvest session where we try
to come up with some ideas and identify
pain points and we kill a lot of sticky
notes in those process because we ask
people to write down ideas that they
might have to identify pain points that
they think people are having and we we
wallpaper the walls with those kinds of
things and then through a process of
consolidation we really try to focus in
on what seems to be the real issues here
and to become creative with what are
some of the solutions that we might
apply to that when you create those
kinds of tools you can often come up
with an opportunity map which you might
you know define sectors of it in terms
of types of of people that you're
designing for or on a scale from little
from stationary to mobility for example
but to really look at what are some of
the opportunities in terms of solutions
and very quickly you look at solutions
that are beyond were you intended to go
necessarily so like as I mentioned we
were talking about tablets and looking
at devices when we were talking about
mobility and when we began this study
but we it became very obvious by the end
of the study that it wasn't just the
device it was about you know
connectivity was about you know the
software that enabled people to access
or to retrieve information from a
medical record it was a much larger and
rich ecosystem and so we began to think
beyond devices to serve
is the software to other kinds of things
that needed to be bundled together in
order to create this better vision of
the future usually within an opportunity
map or in in concurrence with it you
might do something like a SWOT analysis
where you get strengths weaknesses
opportunities and threats and it also
helps you to identify well okay I maybe
I want to make this change in an
electronic health record but what does
that mean in terms of the regulatory
environment and the you know the
environment of who is controlling EHRs
and all this kind of stuff so it again
begins to open up your mind to
possibilities as well as things that you
need to do in order to get to your goal
it's going to be very useful road
mapping exercise so I will conclude with
this slide which is a kind of a collage
of various research opportunities that
we did both in terms of the VA and
primary care and the mobility research
we did and just reiterate that you know
we think that this this approach clearly
has value and at until you know we've
been using ethnography for many years
now and it's sort of recognized
company-wide that this has some value to
show in terms of the kinds of ideas and
the solutions that we come up with so i
think it's it's a fertile area for
anthropologists i know that there as i
mentioned other people who are also
involved in this kind of work who come
from a variety of disciplinary
backgrounds but i think i encourage you
for those of you who are thinking about
methodologies for PhD work you might
want to consider something like a bit of
an authority to help you flesh out your
your thought process some it's sometimes
works very hand in glove with more
quantitative kinds of work because it
helps to explain what's happening in one
realm or helps you prepare for the
quantitative if it is become much more
acceptable in terms of a unique kind of
our singular kind of research for
dissertation projects as well I'm happy
to see that more and more journals or
accepting research that's quantitative
qualitative and orientation so it
certainly has come to rise in academic
as well as more industry kinds of
evers so I think we have a fair amount
of time for questions so if anybody's
got any please pipe up yeah I think I'll
start now I also want to remind anyone
who asks a question to push the button
on the microphone in front of them so it
gets recorded to the recording of this
talk so that people who listen to it can
hear it the question I want to ask is
that sometimes there is a little bit of
a disconnect between sort of the user
experience and focus on specific tasks
and one of the big tasks in healthcare
and certainly in informatics now is to
use the buzzword data analytics you know
people doing things with with data and
one of the big problems with data
analytics is the less than optimal
quality of the data that goes into
system so the question is are you aware
of any work or do you have any thoughts
on how we can build systems that help
users not only have a better user
experience but also generate but but
also collect good data for all the kind
of myriad of reuses of that data that we
hope to see like you know quality
measurement those sorts of things I'm
thinking of a few things so one that one
is improving the user experience for the
data entry and that could be making the
the the interface the user interface
more friendly or more customizable to
match the idiosyncratic need of the
particular clinician we notice that that
people have their own way of doing
things and so an inflexible system
sometimes leads to people just choosing
not to do parts of it the other thing
that that we've been talking about is
different ways of getting data in so if
writing something down is is too
cumbersome if keyboarding in is too
cumbersome are there ways that we could
use voice for example or gesture other
kinds of techniques in order to get the
data into those things aligned with that
would be the use of sensor data so
rather than having people take vitals
and enter it in is you know can we do
more about porting information to
luckily into the EHR so that that
information is there and then the fourth
area that we've been looking at to is
how can for things like quality
reporting how can we use the data that
is in there that may be coming from
these more automatic sources and just be
able to process them in a way that
provides that completes those fields
that fills in the information that you
need without someone having to go in and
do it and I think finally to having
devices that are available at point of
care they make a big difference too
because if you're relying on you know
someone's notes and then the recopying
of it there's there's a margin for error
there and then also if someone's
remembering at retaining in their head
and then going back and documenting it
later pieces of it may fall out so you
touched on participatory design when you
talked about the workshops and I know
the students have been really interested
in that in the past I wondered if you
could expand on it for us as i mentioned
i think it's it's a really useful way to
tapping into information that you might
not otherwise get because it allows
gives people the lead in terms of the
research or what they tell you and it
also i think just that it's a playful
process many times and so it enables
people to think about things in
different ways instead of am giving you
sort of a standard face-saving answer
they might come up with something that's
more creative and digs a little bit
deeper into their own emotional pool so
I think that's useful there are a
variety of different tools that people
use so the format for those of you not
familiar with it it's sort of like a
focus group only it involves people
actually engaged not just telling you
things but actually doing something with
you or for you some techniques that
people have used are called placemats so
they might give you a topic for example
tell tell me about what your work life
is like and then there's a ray of
pictures and words and other kinds of
stimuli that people could put together
and create this place mat with all this
collage of these different kinds of
things and then they go through and
explain different pieces of it that
to eliminate what they're thinking about
sometimes we give people actual or
pretend devices to work with us see if I
can get to this slide that helped them
to again to think kind of creatively and
even play act there and this one here we
gave people who were part of a clinical
team right there pretend devices so we
had like laptops we had phones we had
tablets we had all these different
things that were just constructed out of
paper but they were meant to make people
think about what devices they would use
in a particular interaction and in this
case it was about discharging people
from the hospital on how to facilitate
that so it gives people things again to
be creative with stimulate some thought
process on their part and a piece we
added to this is that they had to
play-act what the discharge would look
like if they had these other tools so we
had people who were you know pretending
to be the cell phone or talking on the
piece of cardboard and once again it
gives you a different flavor for what
what people are thinking about and how
you might go about creating a solution
so people have used a variety of
different tools for them but I think
that they're they're really useful in
terms of the hands-on and a look into
sort of the emotion and the creativity
behind things
I was interested to see your post it
notes as you're doing your opportunity
map have you explored technology
applications that might simulate that
type of posted experience particularly
for people maybe that are collaborating
remotely that's a great question we have
done some of that some white boarding
via link and other things with people
who are remote and sending messages and
things like that we've also had people
participate remotely by having them on a
video camera and and sort of sending by
instant message there there little
sticky note that we put on the main wall
but at least what i have found to date
is that there's something about that
process of having them all on the wall
and looking at them and collaborating on
how you move them together in the
clusters that i haven't found a
technological substitute for and is
similar to the you know the
brainstorming with the dot pray or
either you get five dots and yamp it i
mean there is something about the
physical interaction and kind of seeing
what other people are doing yeah we have
tried I'm doing the whiteboard thing
remotely with resounding failure because
it's hard you know other than staff
writing on it it was hard to get that
participants to contribute and I think
you have you know as much as we all try
to participate when we when we are
remote there's something about the
accountability of being in the room that
helps to focus people's attention to and
so I think that the participation and
the creativity helps it seems to work
better that way unfortunately yeah you
might be you've been doing some research
in primary care mm-hmm tell us more
about that sure that's a little older
research it's a few years old now but
what we did in that study was to shadow
primary care doctors in there in five
different cities in the US and we spent
a couple of days with each of them to
try to understand what their workflow
process was some of them were completely
electronic in terms of their
documentation some of them were still
exclusively paper but again we were
trying to understand what were some of
the constraints to adoption of
Technology
gee and how people who were the early
adopters were using what they had we
also had the opportunity as it turned
out to be at a couple practices where
people were transitioning so we got to
sort of be there with them in their pain
as they were trying to convert the paper
into electronic documentation and that
was really helpful for us to understand
really just what kind of commitment it
took for someone who was in practice for
10 or 15 years to make that transition
and try to you know get all those
documents electronically so it was one
of the things that I think we understood
from that too is how idiosyncratic the
documentation processes were in each of
those offices we had people who were
using you know either a homemade EHR or
trying to modify one that they bought
off the shelf even people who were using
paper records had different forms that
they were using we had one doctor who
had created this big rubber stamp and
put it on a piece of paper and have
these different fields that he would use
so you know it makes you makes us think
about how nimble software needs to be in
order to respond to people's needs you
have to have all this there are criteria
for what kind of what gets documented
and I think people go through medical
school and learn certain ways of
documenting data but you know beyond
that there are things that people like
to do their own way and so how can we
facilitate software do that yeah earlier
you had an image of a bunch of
clinicians gathered around particular
monitor or screen has your work inspired
the development of any collaborative
technologies and do you have any
specific examples well I know we are
working on some technologies to enable
that I'm not sure how how public the
mbox tuck is but we're working on on
some ways to help people well we're
looking at a couple of things we're
looking at leveraging existing kinds of
software that you know we might use in a
corporate setting to enable clinicians
to talk to each other but we're also
looking at some other things and where
we could embed software and devices that
would facilitate you know video
conferencing and audio conferencing and
leaving voice messages and
like that that so yeah we're trying to
comprehend that but we're still in the
works on that one I think that going
into these places and doing this kind of
research that these kind of methods
would lead to being surprised a lot and
in a way that would be you know one of
the best outcomes right and is that true
and can you tell us a couple of examples
of your favorite surprises sure yes and
no I mean I think that there are
occasions of surprise but particularly
when we do a larger scale study or do it
for a longer time we begin to pick out
patterns and see some consistencies in
terms of what the needs are across all
those different settings in terms of
some surprises the picture that I showed
you of the the doctor who was
keyboarding on on a chair I think that
was a new exposure to me particularly to
do that kind of research and home care
I've done we shadowed home health nurses
and some other folks who've done
delivered care in the home but this is a
program that the VA has that provides
all of primary care to people to
qualified veterans in their own home so
they don't have to go into the clinic
and I think it was a combination of the
comprehensiveness of the care that was
being delivered as well as some of the
circumstances that the veterans found
themselves in that it was really
enlightening to see what people were
contending with you know well beyond
just like the normal part of doing a
blood draw or checking someone's vitals
all these other psycho social and
environmental things that people were
dealing with as they try to do their job
and for folks who had laptops that
couldn't even hold a charge for more
than four hours like how could we expect
him to bring that into the you know
these environments there were a lot of
other questions and so that was a really
eye-opening experience I think and you
know I have done research in hospitals
as well and over the years the
technology changes the course and so
what was a problem five years ago is not
a problem now but there are new problems
that were created by the fixes for the
problems and so I think we always have
to go in there with with fresh eyes and
not not assume that we know a situation
because we were well grounded in it a
couple of years ago even so that's
something that we have to remind
ourselves each time we go in and not get
too jaded or too complacent terms of
what we're looking at
so you know I think the qualitative
research that you do you know provides a
really unique perspective to a lot of
situations but sometimes you know the
quantitative piece can add value as well
have you done any sort of mixed methods
where you've tried to integrate the two
and and had any success and do they
agree to they disagree mm-hmm we have
and I have done I did a lot of that when
i was at Kaiser we did a lot of mixed
methodology work so it does work a
couple of ways that it does more
currently we might we might conduct
surveys of clinicians to understand you
know what they think are their pain
points and that helps to guide us when
we go out into the field so we kind of
know what questions to ask or what
things to focus on so it's a sometimes a
very good precursor to the work that
we're doing it also helps us when we're
doing more what I would label usability
kind of research where we might you know
actually have tasks that people do and
quantify how they're doing in the speed
at which they're doing it so once again
that's a very good connection between
the two I've also used qualitative
research to help understand what's going
on in quantitative research so we might
get some results and say you know what's
going on there that I don't quite
understand that or I want to dig a
little deeper here and that that forms
the basis for the qualitative research
to follow up on that and help us to
understand a little bit more so they I
think they'd work very well together
all right thank you